so what are we noticing here right there
are two big important things number one
unlike all of the graphs and class you
look up at this one for a second again
placing all of the functions we looked
at before right wouldn't you
differentiated them number one you've
got something radically different didn't
you right
you changed the power you changed like
it's this weird you likes got asymptotes
on economy you got weird and unusual
things but they were very different but
well we had a look at these
Exponential's when you differentiate an
exponential because of the shape of it
right
it starts off gentle and slow and then
it's skyrockets up the derivative is
doing exactly the same thing it starts
off low and then it's so skyrockets off
but then there's this very specific
value where hmm not only stay not only
is your derivative very much like your
original function if you can pick just
the right value for this exponential
right if you pick just the right value
the derivative is not just like the
original function the derivative is the
original function okay that's so
important you said again right if you
start with an exponential function and
if you pick the value of this base just
so then the derivative that you get is
not close to the original function it is
exactly the same and it's that number
right there 2.718 now it would be a bit
awkward to say 2.718 and all of the rest
of the decimal places because hopefully
you've noticed you might have tried to
get closer right there are more and more
decimal places after this right bit
awkward to say things like that so when
we take this number which clearly has to
do with exponential functions right
right it's a number to do with
Exponential's and I'm just too lazy to
say all of that so we give this number a
name well instead of calling this number
to do with Exponential's we call it a
and in fact if you get your arm get your
scientific calculator out if you have
not already
thank you if you get your calculator out
you might have noticed just hiding there
on the top right hand corner of your
calculator right just above or just
below the factorial button do you see
just below in yellow it's so small it's
hiding this you can't see did you see it
says what does it say II and then
there's a little block because it says e
^ now here's what I'd like you do I'm
gonna pitch this for a second if that's
okay
let's see if I can switch this over so
you can actually see is there gonna be a
tissue box I think there is
come on tissue box there we go alright
alright so this your calculator right
sorry I've just pitched yours now if you
press shift to get to that right if you
press shift let's put a light on shall
we
that might help here we go if you press
shift and then that button do you
already you did okay now you can see
here it's prompting us for a power now
just think about why that is for a
second this number that we're interested
in we're only interested in in the
context of Exponential's raising things
to powers right but I actually want to
know what that number itself precisely
is equals we tried to approximate it on
desmos so to get what that number is you
would want e to the power of what that
would just give you eight so if you
press either power of one go ahead hit
equals yes I'll come to that one a bit
later on it's a different thing okay we
worked this lower case one you've got
some numbers there right
oh our lamp is doing a funny thing isn't
it there we go
magic all right now have a look at that
have a look at that for a second two
point seven one eight we kind of got to
that right and then it just keeps going
to eight one two it now you have to be
very cautious in mathematics when things
look like they are a patent but they may
not be right do you notice it's like oh
look at that
one eight two eight then there's a one
eight two eight again it's very tempting
to think that there are more one eight
two eight on the end here and it could
be that there actually are not and
hopefully you've got your you've
what your desmos open they're still
right if you go back to desmos go there
and start a new function on the bottom
left-hand corner here now des mots knows
that e is a special name for a special
thing
so unlike f and a and all these other
things if you just go ahead and on your
keyboard tap in e it was hiding all
along it knew this whole time and it
just gave it to us in a more precise
form so you can see there 2.71828 one
eight two eight like we saw in our
calculator display but then our
calculator just kind of gives up it's
like I can't do any more decimal places
right but you can see there's more
numbers after here that are not the same
repeating pattern in fact is one of
those special kind of numbers like pi or
the square root of two it doesn't have
any kind of repeating pattern to it it's
completely irrational right in fact it's
more than irrational it's another kind
of quality called transcendental but
we'll get to that another time okay yeah
cool day right for a cool number so can
we please in your books write your first
heading was revision you can make a new
heading which is exponential
just exponential
depends what you mean by real okay but
not other words yet people we spent all
that time to lay this groundwork down so
what we've got here what we've just
discovered in or uncovered as a better
word for it I think is this special
lumbar e right so it's the exponential
number it's the number that all
Exponential's are kind of leaning toward
we call it a for exponential Eddie is
two points now let's have another go
let's see how many of these we could
write right now one of the ways I
remember is that we'd patent that seemed
to emerge but it wasn't actually a
patent right so after the seven we get
one eight two eight and then you get M
doesn't 182 eight then desmos hopefully
gave us a couple more four and then a
six and then it just keeps on going it
just keeps it in fact if you want to
open up Excel that'll give you plenty of
decimal places so now have you got a few
more ok great we've looked up at that
that's good you can go to Google you can
get millions of digits of eight just
like yet millions of digits of pi it's a
very important number but the the really
amazing thing about it was this quality
we noticed if we took the derivative of
the exponential function where this was
the base let me say that again if we
took the derivative of the exponential
function where this number 2.71 a pop of
allah was the base what did we observe
what happened to the different
derivative the gradient function yeah it
was exactly the same it was what you
started with bless you right in other
words if you differentiate this EDX
business the answer is e to the X
it's that same exponential function this
is weird
every other function you have ever
differentiate in your entire life you
differentiate and you get some weird
other thing out the front at the end
right like we demonstrated this morning
but even the X is unique you
differentiate it and you get it back
okay
to put a big box around this right e to
the X is the function that is its own
derivative that's so important or even
right it may be the X is the function
and I hope even underlined the word V
because there's only one a VX is the
function that is its own derivative
correct so this is the weird crazy thing
about why we spent so much time to
develop this idea right it is unique
among all the functions you will ever
discover there is no ever one other
other one you will encounter that has
the same property which i think is
pretty crazy ok now what this there does
is it leads us to a whole different
family of things we can have a look at
we've known how differentiate
polynomials right X ^ whatever this is
not a polynomial this is something to
the power of X we've never really
operated with this thing when X is up
there in the exponent in the power but
now we care